[Music]
hi everybody my name is a lot of other
Besant's and I'm a student in Stanford
GSB MBA program and I'm actually in this
class called strategic communications
and we're doing final projects and this
is actually my final presentation we're
going to talk about how to start a
speech and it's a group presentation so
I want to introduce everyone stop I need
you to stop right there that is not how
you want to start the presentation that
was that was rough and the opener to a
presentation is the most important part
so why don't you sit down take a look
and we'll teach you the right way to
start a presentation how many of you can
remember being at a speech and giving up
on the speaker within the first 30
seconds of them talking now keep your
hand up if you're sure you've never been
that speaker it never will be
that's why we're here to teach you the
formula for a great first 90 seconds to
any presentation get it right and you
have the perfect setup for a winning
presentation get it wrong and it's
almost impossible to win your audience
and that formula starts with something
called an opening gambit like my
question or even better a compelling
story when Steve Jobs walked up the
stage on the Mac Board conference twelve
years ago everyone was expecting
something special the room was packed
with thousands of Apple enthusiasts and
the lights were dimmed and all you can
see you can see was a giant Apple logo
on the main screen so the Steve walked
slowly to the middle of the stage this
black turtleneck and he started strong
said every once in a while a
revolutionary product comes along that
changes everything and the audience was
absolutely magnetized few minutes later
they learned that the product is the new
Apple iPhone the first Apple iPhone the
anecdote like this is a great way to
start your story and capture your
audience immediately the book presenting
to win by Jerry Weisman gives you as
much as seven opening gambits like this
opening strategies today we'll give you
three of them the anecdote is they just
started is the first one it's a short
story with a human angle and it's
effective because we have a natural
tendency to relate to other people to
care about other people and you can make
a potentially boring topic come to life
with a vivid story second one is a
question directed that the members of
your audience this is sound a couple of
minutes ago
it evokes immediate response and it
captures your audience attention makes
them think how your message relates to
them the third one is a factory so it's
a simple statistic or a factual
statement can you market trend
demographic trend for example it takes
JD as much as 60 minutes to create each
student's presentation this has to be
related directly to your to your speech
and the more unusual striking and
surprising it is the better but an
opening gambit is not all that you need
in order to can your presentation
started you've already started strong
you've gotten the audience's attention
and you've also given them a reason to
keep their mobile devices so for the
duration of the flight
so like any pilot now you need to tell
them where your flight is headed to and
why they shouldn't be heading for the
exits and you can do this in two ways so
the first way is this idea of a unique
setting composition or USP for short
right there's the school I think that's
you know relatively intuitive but in the
context of a speech a USP is
kind of like the elevator pitch it tells
your audience what you're gonna say
and why what you're gonna say is gonna
be valuable to them it's an elevator
pitch and so therefore it should be sure
and you're thinking one to two sentences
rather than you know like a full-length
novel more like in the second summary
and we kind of demonstrated this to you
earlier when Sam took the stage from
Alana and said that we were going to
spend the rest of this presentation
teaching you share with you the formula
for how you can start your presentations
well if you go back to Steve Jobs he
also had the USP when he opened his
presentation and he said that at manual
27 2007 they were going to announce a
product that was going to revolutionize
the mobile industry and if you're
sitting in the audience that day that
immediately draws you in because there
was a lot of anticipation building up
Mac wall is you know that Mac even that
Apple always holds and there have been a
lot of hype building up to that
particular event so oK we've got the USP
out of the way the second thing I want
to share is this idea of a truth of
concept and if you think of the USP as
that thing that makes the audience want
to listen to you the proof of concept
speaks to your credibility why should
the audience listen to you what's so
special about you that gives you that
authority that credibility to talk about
the subject that you intend to present
one I can give you a few examples of
what a PLC might look like proof of
concept so first example is you could
talk about your historical success your
track record last year we sold 50
million copies of our product we expect
to do the same this year second example
could be a reference to a reputable
source or credible Authority arrest Ron
earned two stars in last year's Michigan
last example I have would be to look at
to look at our to deliver progress
update on something that you've been
working on so how many of you guys have
been following the news on the commas in
girls self-driving trucks okay so I
could say last month we successfully
concluded a pilot trial with the US
Postal Service using autonomous
self-driving trucks to travel between
Utah and Michigan so those are some
reason those are some examples and if
you use both a USP as well as a fusee
effectively I think you're gonna find
that you're gonna be able to draw your
audience in starting from an opening
gambit and moving into the bulk of your
presentation and that's gonna keep them
engaged for the duration of your flight
and also for the duration of your
presentation so this all all all great
advice now we learn how we should how we
should start the presentation I'm gonna
touch on the tops we shouldn't do so
first we should never start by
introducing ourselves or describing the
company we work for you remember you
Lana it was deadly boring how she
started this presentation by introducing
herself and recall Sam who started with
opening gambit questions so he managed
to capture your interest and could
engage with limited second don't start
with a joke
everyone likes good jokes and we are not
an exception but to predict a success or
failure of job is almost impossible even
if your job creates a lot and it's
successful it will rather distract your
audience from your persuasive message
third don't use banal overused
quotations quotes
I mean quotes by William Shakespeare
Benjamin Franklin or by other famous
people but the I would add a small
caveat here you can use them only if
they're very specifically really
to your company so for example if I were
the CEO of a voice-to-text company I
would say easier said than done it would
be very effective
so Ivana you heard all the tips we
shared with you now do you want to give
another shot sure can you all please do
something with me I want you to help me
count to 15 1 3 4 5 6 9 10 11 15 seconds
it's not very long that's how long you
have to make a first impression on your
audience and that's why it is really
important that you open your speech
strong if you don't capture your
audience's attention with the beginning
of your speech you're probably never
going to get it and that's a shame
because everybody in this room has ideas
that are worth listening to
so some people are intimidated by the
idea of starting a speech and coming up
with that really good opening but it
doesn't have to be that hard we're going
to give you a simple formula for acing
the first 90 seconds of any speech you
get it starts with an opening gambit
that really captures your audience's
attention like a good story or an
interesting fact that surprises them it
then moves into a unique selling
proposition where you tell your audience
why they should listen to you what
benefits you promise to deliver to them
optionally you can then include a proof
of concept which is a demonstration that
you're actually going to be able to
provide those benefits that you just
promised and we have already seen this
formula work really well if you think
back to Wednesday when Casey came
storming in here with the start of that
d-day speech
I think everyone sat up at attention a
little bit who were there and he quickly
moved into tying
to the actual topic of the presentation
and telling us why we should care about
what his team had to say about small
talk she both engaged her interest and
set up an overarching metaphor like his
entire speech so what we urge you to do
is this the next time you have a
presentation to make whether it's for
work or for school pay special attention
to how you start and follow this formula
if you do your audience will listen to
your great ideas well that was a much
better job Ilana no thanks I'm really
glad you listened to our presentation
before trying that again don't worry
we're not going to now do our entire
presentation again instead we'd love to
take this time to open it up for your
questions we'd love to hear more
[Music]